all right welcome welcome to data
council thursdays
i'm pete soderling i'm the responder
data council and the data community fund
and i'm super excited to welcome you to
dc thursdays
where we sit down with leaders of top
open source data projects
so if you've ever wondered why the data
engineering world doesn't resemble the
rest of software engineering
in terms of automated testing tools like
great expectations
are helping to bring us out of the dark
ages great expectations
helps teams eliminate pipeline debt
through data testing
documentation and profiling
indeed pipeline debt is a term coined by
abegong
in a medium post back in february 2018
that struck a chord and channeled a
significant amount of angst
out of data community as data engineers
finally felt they had found someone who
understood the pain they had been
feeling
and was advocating not just a clear
conceptual framework
but even more importantly an actual tool
to solve this problem
so i couldn't be more excited to welcome
a man himself abe gong to the show
ava's a co-author of the great
expectations data testing framework
and is also the co-founder of super
conductive the company he launched to
support the development of great
expectations
and also to provide commercial options
for its advancement
abe was previously the chief data
scientist at aspire health
and also the first data scientist at
jawbone
so hey welcome to the show
thanks pete it's awesome to be here i
this is the first time right this is the
first show of this
postcode new whatever we're going into
in terms of conference formats
this is the first time and um it's the
first time most people have you know
seen us with our new haircuts
uh pose quarantine haircuts so we were
lucky enough to
get appointments prior to chattering
today um
but yeah we're kicking it off this is uh
this is ground zero
awesome it's good to be here yeah thanks
abe
so um i let's get right into it um
uh data testing um data quality
in your view why are these things
important
um we've got a little spiel that we do
now
um which is we put it this way we
actually i did this for the first time
at data council back in november
but i i think this resonates it's worth
describing to this many people
so if you're a software engineer and you
build a really cool api
and you say hey i've got this really
cool api and i'm going to
ship it to production and i want you as
other people to start relying on it
but by the way it's not documented and
there are no tests
for it oh and it might change and i i
wouldn't even know if it changed so
you know good luck with that i think in
the rest of the engineering world
software engineering world you would
look at that and say this is that is
totally crazy
that like does not like that's not
really really engineering yet
um you've got a thing that works right
now but you can't guarantee it's going
to work in the future that
it's just hard to rely on we've got a
lot of people that are relying on data
systems
and weirdly uh you know if you look at
the average table in the average data
warehouse
most of them aren't tested most of them
aren't documented and a lot of them
change without warning
so we see data quality as i mean
it's these like two little words you can
put on all kinds of pain and frustration
that come out of relying on things that
haven't been fully engineered to be
reliable
and did you know that your medium post
would hit striker
strike such a cord with the community
when you were preparing it back a couple
years ago i mean you never know with
those things
i had a hunch uh just because i had
experienced that pain
in every job that i worked at and i know
a lot of very good data engineers and we
talked about similar things
so i i knew that we were onto a real
pattern
uh what i don't think i could have
predicted is how many other people
see the world the same way and uh really
liked that framing of it
it's been really cool to see i mean like
i'm certainly not the only person
advancing thoughts in this area but to
see that specific set of thoughts
gain momentum and traction and and
snowball over the last couple years
and by the way you're saying that this
is my post we
um i just want to make sure to give
total credit to james campbell
who is my co-author on the library from
very early on
um and more recently other people like
eugene mandel
uh alex rutinski i'm not gonna be able
to name everybody on the super deductive
team but like it's an awesome team and
it's definitely a group effort and even
beyond that
we've i'm we're we're not quite at 100
contributors on the project but we'll
probably get there
in the next few months uh so it's
increasing like
i it's kind of fun being the figurehead
for this thing sometimes but i'm not
doing most of the thinking of the work
that's what i want to say well that's
great the team is important
um and how did you personally though get
sort of dragged into this space i find
that
many times the best origin stories um
from some of the best tools or
companies from the founders themselves
there's almost a force of nature
involved in sort of what
what dragged them into the into this
opportunity and and what was happening
for you that sort of made you realize
that you were in the right place at the
right time and had a perspective on this
stuff that could be valuable
i think that i mean there's been a
couple moments on that the most recent
one
like the most recent big one was last
year um
i was running this company super
conductive it was actually originally
founded to be a data consulting company
for health care
we were super conductive health and last
year we started to get a bunch of
inbound requests from
people i'd never met but nothing to do
with healthcare and
they they would say like hey we know
you've got something to do with this
library
uh we've got real data quality issues we
like the way you're thinking about it
and even though we're not healthcare
like
we've got dollars can you like help us
solve this problem
um and as an entrepreneur after you get
a certain number of those calls and say
okay something's really happening here
this seems to be a broad horizontal
thing
so yeah and that was a real pull moment
and how would you say that teams are
solving their data quality issues
now like what does that look like or at
least sort of pre great expectations
um what sorts of tools or scripts or
checks or
like how did folks cobble together stuff
um before this
this sort of data ops era that we're
stepping into
i think cobble together is the right
language for it um
you see a lot of people home growing
systems
of big companies will sometimes put
together something that looks kind of
like great expectations
uh and you know made that a framework
um sentinel out of linkedin for example
was
uh published some of their stuff
recently there's a lot of
philosophical things that i agree with
in that project um smaller companies
it's usually just people and maybe some
scripts
uh and i i've met a lot of companies
where
you know somebody every night at 10
o'clock has to sign in
run some scripts against the data
warehouse and then copy paste the
results into slack
and ooh if something's wrong okay well
then somebody gets called 10 o'clock at
night
um so it's it's messy
and so like moving into um some topics
specific to great expectations itself um
what were some of the design principles
that you used when you started to
imagine what a world could look like
with better quality data testing tools
like what were your guiding principles
we made one decision very early on that
i
i think it was intuitive also strategic
at the time we just we felt like you
could unlock more
if you did it this way um and that was
the notion that
expectation like so this notion of an
expectation an assertion about data
well first it should be an assertion
about the data not about the code
because in data systems data is the
thing that is changing more frequently
and if you want to really guard yourself
against you know the vagaries of
unpredictable change
you've got to test that that's that's
where most of the complexity lives so
that was one
thing that i think was genuinely new at
the time um the other
decision that we made was to do a
declarative language
and to say hey yes of course you can
always
write your own little custom sql snippet
or a few lines of pandas code or
something like that
but in order for these assertions to be
as valuable as possible
they should be semantically meaningful
which means that having them as clear
declarative things
expect column values to be in set or
expect column mean to be between
being able to assert it that way would
create a lot more
value in the long term and i think
that's been borne out
there's actually more to come there but
we're already seeing that worn out in a
very clear way
so the core abstraction of the system is
this notion of an expectation
surrounding your data you have stock
expectations that sort of come pre-baked
in addition to
presumably user-defined versions or
flavors of this
that's right so out of the box uh great
expectation ships with about 50
uh custom sorry custom standard
expectations
they're domain agnostic so null values
uh date times um sets
ranges means medians maxes the kind of
standard things that apply everywhere
and then we've also got the capability
to extend the library with your own
custom expectations
got it and so how would you describe the
main use cases
of the tool um
i think the main use it's a big question
um so sometimes we get asked like hey is
this an etl
assistant is this good for machine
learning do i use my data warehouse
and the answer is yes like all of those
use cases
um one of the things that we've worked
really hard to do in great expectations
is make it as infrastructure agnostic
as possible so you can execute the same
expectations in pandas
in spark and against almost anything
that supports sql alchemy
now a lot of libraries there are still
building out into some of those edge
cases some of the lesser used databases
but what that means is anybody who's
dealing with data flowing through a
system that touches multiple pieces of
infrastructure
you can use consistent terminology again
this declarative thing
uh and consistent expectations and make
sure that it holds together at each
stage even if there are a lot of jumps
through your data pipeline
and and this is specifically designed to
be implemented on
sort of on batch
in batch mode correct
yes although i don't want to take
streaming off the table forever
um what i'll say is there are a lot of
expectations that make the most sense to
evaluate
in chunks of data in batches of data so
for example if you want to check the
mean
or if you want to verify that you know
no more than 95 percent
uh or sorry uh at least 95 percent of
values
are not null those two things only make
sense in the presence of a batch
um that said we we think you know down
the road
there's probably room to extend the
terminology upstream into the streaming
systems of the world
got it interesting um
i want to mention to the audience as
well that um we'll save some time for
questions at the end so
you can feel free to contribute your
questions um in the youtube chat
and we'll do our best to get them
answered um once eve and i finish our
conversation so please
jump in the youtube chat and let us know
uh any questions that you have for abe
as well
so um so back to ge um
when does an engineer typically empty by
the way i
love that you call i love that you call
it ge that so much
you was an insider on this
not not the monolith or the the huge
multinational
um company with that brand you're not
concerned about
um infringement or you know uh sort of
abbreviation colloquialisms i have to
talk to lawyers blah blah blah
we we sometimes joke about this we say
like if this gets big
we're competing with like the two worst
group uh worst but two tough groups for
for seo one is ge the company and the
others charles dickens
and those are both hard seo fights well
neither are sponsors of the show so i
think we're safe for now
is that how it works okay
so um so when when an engineer typically
implements a tool how does what does
that look like
so uh what we usually see is people
come in and uh start off when i say c
i'm generalizing here from conversations
with
lots and lots of uh users in our slack
channel
so we've got almost a thousand people in
the great expectation slack channel just
just wonderful and amazing it didn't
exist a year ago and
now there's all this momentum um
what we typically see is people will
come in and do one of two things to get
started
um some people say hey i just want to
kick the tires i'm not sure that i need
this i'm not quite sure how it works
so i just want to play with this notion
of an expectation in a notebook
so you know let me load that up in a
data frame and then experiment with it
and
poke at it for a while um we've got some
good early tutorials on that we're
actually refreshing those right now to
make them
kind of fully up to date with all the
latest changes
uh so that that's one workflow the other
workflow that usually comes after that
is if a team that has kind of read
enough to be confident and like feels
enough pain
around um around the need for data
quality monitoring data documentation
they say yeah we should we want
something like this and we're ready to
to get started in that case uh if you
just
hip install great expectations and then
do great expectations in it
it'll walk you through the process of a
deeper setup
so that's everything from configuring
what we call the data context which is
sort of the manager for all the
all the relevant pieces to configuring
data sources to building your first set
of expectations to setting up
what we call a checkpoint which is a way
to schedule and monitor
um data quality checking oh and data
documentation as well
actually we haven't said this here uh
it's probably worth mentioning
one of the cool things that comes out of
this declarative syntax for expectations
is you can compile your tests into your
documentation
and um it what we found is
i'd say the promise of this is still
early there's still quite a bit more to
do to like fully develop this part of
the ecosystem
but um the notion that
your docs can be your tests and your
tests can be your docs and that they'll
always stay in sync
and they'll always as long as you're
running your tests they'll always
reflect the current underlying reality
of the data
that's a that's a nifty promise it's not
a thing that has existed before
uh like most data teams that i know have
the chronically stale wiki
that tries to document the data but like
it's almost like you have to do your
work all over again
to make sure that the wiki is up to date
uh and so it so never is of course
um i i wouldn't say we have completely
fulfilled on the promise
of taking all the friction out of that
workflow but
i think we're the best game in town for
it and it's exciting to
see people pushing on that contributing
to making it happen
yeah that's super neat because to me
that represents um
a touchstone for a broader collaboration
opportunity
with teams as well because no longer is
the the quality and the um origin
and sort of the the responsibility of
the
data flowing the system you know only
one of the data engineer but the data
engineer has the opportunity through
ge to basically establish this this
vocabulary
um do you call it a data dictionary i
mean
these are some we're sort of blending
some terms from
older eras but um like how like there's
also the data catalog
concept which we'll actually be talking
to
mark grover from lyft about um in our
next episode um
but separately separately from that do
you see
ge as potentially powering i mean first
of all collaboration
across um different types of roles in
the data
ecosystem or the business ecosystem and
also
like could it become potentially the
foundation for
um data dictionary data catalog um these
other sorts of concepts that
we also know the world needs
um okay two parts on that so one
yes absolutely on speaking to what we
think of as developer adjacent roles
so one of the things that we've been
very conscious of with developing great
expectations
is we want it to be super super
developer friendly
uh it works with notebooks it plays with
all the infrastructure people have
already
we've kind of bent over backwards to
make it customizable and pluggable and
extensible
so that as an engineer or a data
scientist and somebody who writes code
you're always in total control of what
it does um of course we can make a lot
of things easier too
that said part of the part of our job as
being like really developer friendly
is to help developers collaborate with
all of the people who sit next to them
i think a thing that is different about
the data world than most other types of
software engineering
is in software engineering most of the
kind of the inputs and the outputs and
the moving parts
they're self-contained like if as an
engineer you really understand how your
stuff works
then you understand most of what you
need to know um
in data we've always got this notion of
a data generating process right
something that happens in the real world
that then flows into your system and
because so much of what is happening
in the data system is being driven by
that upstream dgp
there's always going to be a tighter
collaboration between
the data folk like the engineering type
data folks working within
the the software and data system and
then all of those adjacent roles who
understand
like why like what's happening upstream
why does it do what it needs what it
does what should it do
um and so the the need for collaboration
across those boundaries
is i think relatively large in data
relative to everywhere else
uh and so uh kind of empowering
communication like fluid communication
across roles and across different skill
sets it is a big part of what we want to
be able to do
got it so coming back to the stocks
feature um
what sort of the next steps on making
that even more robust where are you now
and where are you headed with that and
then your future
so i actually think there's a there's a
hop in the middle which is
what we've called data profiling um
we've tried to be very open about this
that
data profiling is still sort of an
experimental feature
we're now in a place where there's a
great expectation scaffold command
that's pretty good there's still a lot
that can be done
but it's a pretty good starting
experience to get in and
not have to write all of your tests for
yourself
um and to have power tools that allow
you to
do those workflows kind of many at a
time again there's still more to do
there
but the way i see this flowing through
is
as we enable users to just fluidly
create
more expectations to build out their
test suites and build coverage
you know deeper wider thicker faster um
you you move from a place where you have
to kind of do a piecemeal to a place
where you start to be able to actually
bring large chunks of your data pipeline
under test very quickly and the
the output from that yes it's testing
but it also does start to look like a
data catalog
and the way we're thinking of it is
if you already have a data catalog we
want to be able to flow into that and
kind of pipe our output through so that
it enriches the experience you've
already got
if you don't have a data catalog at all
then great expectations docs can be kind
of the version
0 of that and then you know like all
good tools you can build on top of it
got it and this profiling um part of the
system
um it sounds like this is very useful in
helping folks get up on
get running on ge like quickly so
um how long does it typically take for a
team to see
results i know through data council for
instance from last year
you had offered some custom consulting
support help to the community
in getting up and running on great
expectations and
of course that was particularly useful
at the time because the tool was
even newer and perhaps didn't have
batteries included
as you like to say um what's the status
now and how long does it take teams to
get quickly
up and running um on the tool so at the
time we were saying
schedule it and i kind of hate this word
but we've never found anything better we
call it a deployathon
and you know we'll like our whole team
will work with your whole team for
a day and we'll get everything up and
running um at this point we're pretty
reliably able to do
what would be done in a deployathon in
an hour maybe 90 minutes
uh as long as everybody comes with
credentials and
most of that is not the mechanics of
going through
and you know making the code work most
of that is discussion about
how do you want to deploy this how do
you want to configure
in your environment so it's mostly about
engineer choice
and what i what i expect to happen over
time
is we'll have sort of standard playbooks
that fall out of that
and we'll be able to kind of productize
that even further
but even even now i'm pretty confident
saying like if you're thinking about
data quality
and you're you know it's a choice
between home growing something or just
kind of keeping cobbling at the other
versus taking an hour or two to get a
first deployment up
i think that's a pretty easy like easy
comparison for most people to make
and are you willing to to guide this
community through those steps um
inside your slack channel for instance
that you mentioned is that the
appropriate
place to um for someone here who's
interested in the tool to kick off that
engagement
yeah so if you're interested definitely
uh jump into our slack channel it's
great expectations dot io
slash slack i will say we're starting to
be bandwidth constrained on that
uh and so you know please speak up and
we'll schedule time
but few months ago it would have been
uh like yeah we'll do that you know
whenever you show up we'll be we'll be
happy to help
we're still trying to be like super high
touch super helpful about getting people
started
but we've got and for the last several
months around 100 many cases more than
100 people showing up
uh every month in our slack channel so
you know just that rate of new arrivals
it's a little bit hard for us to keep up
with everybody who needs really high
touch help
well that's great the community is
growing so big um and so quickly
and i'm sure regardless of whether
you're able to give custom
high-touch um help to each individual
their
common concerns questions um issues
you're sort of able to funnel into other
formats documentation
training talk materials et cetera so i'm
sure that interaction from the community
is helpful either way
yeah i mean one of the things that's
been really cool to see is
and that wasn't really the case six
months ago is
we've got a lot of uh kind of power
users in the slack channel who are
helping other users and talking through
how to get started
and um this is the first time that i've
experienced this
uh as a period
um but just seeing the community start
to really take the reins
overall that's i i think a lot of the
work the core work is still being done
by super conductive and you know we plan
to always
you know push on it and help the corps
move forward but seeing
increasingly other people stepping up
contributing bringing their ideas in
has been has been really cool and it's
one of the big things that we're pushing
on
uh over the summer is streamlining that
and making it so that um
it if you help somebody out it's easy to
catch that
not just in a slack conversation but in
a discourse channel for example
so that you know that temporary
confusion for one person can turn into
permanent learning for the community
um that's great well i definitely have
more questions
i want to ask you about community stuff
surrounding
um just open source in general um but
before we get
there let's talk a little bit more about
um you know some of the specific
features
surrounding ge i'm also curious um
how many tests do you typically see
are required in a common install like
are we talking about
tens of tests or hundreds of tests or
sort of what is i'm sure the scope can
be
all over the board but what's typical um
in your experience
um it depends like so many things it
depends
um but let me tell you what it depends
on
uh it depends partly on kind of the
nature of the data problem
you're confronting uh so if you go back
you know five years
people in the big data community would
talk kind of buzz wordy they talk about
volume variety velocity
um to the extent that you have a variety
problem you probably
want more expectations and the reason is
if you're pulling in data sources from
lots of different places and
normalizing them or pulling them
together into different analytics things
like that
there's just more business logic that
needs to be built and more surface
area for things to potentially go wrong
so
you know to the extent that you have
more variety you're probably going to
have more tests
um one
one common pattern that we see and the
scaffold uh
workflow that i described earlier
supports this is
when people are starting it's easy to
get overwhelmed i like
you'll often see that the master table
that has 500 columns that come in from
dozens and dozens of different places
and the idea of trying to get all of
that under thorough tests immediately
can be overwhelming
um what we find is that there's
i wouldn't call it an 80 20 rule in the
sense of diminishing returns but more in
the sense of just like focused value in
certain places
um usually if you say okay what are the
10 most important columns
to get under thorough test you can
actually give yourself a lot of peace of
mind like a team that goes through and
puts a not precise numbers so don't hold
me to this exactly but
you know five to ten expectations on
each of ten columns
in their most important table or two
there's often this tangible like
okay you know we can count on you know
the things that burned us in the last
six months are not going to burn us
again
um yeah so you can get incredible
leverage immediately
just from going after your biggest
problem problem areas
and um engineers like immediately feel
the benefit from that
yeah that's right and so i i think like
the workflow that we want to support
is get your infrastructure set up
quickly make it so that it's possible to
build the test deploy the tests
and then check the results get your
slack notification and get your static
docs to review them
make that as quick and seamless as
possible encourage people to bring the
like
really critical you know burning on fire
painful today
systems under light test immediately and
then
just like people often do with legacy
code where it's not very well tested in
the past
as you go forward every once in a while
you'll spend a day just adding some
tests
or if you encounter a new bug okay you
fix the bug and then you test it so
you're sure it'll never happen again
and there's the sense of uh this nice
ratchet effect
where you don't have to do a ton of up
front work to be confident that okay
maybe i'm still going to encounter some
bugs but each time i do i know it's the
last time i'm going to encounter it
because it's under test after that
so are there any anti-patterns
that you see emerging around ge or
um are there any specific types of
projects or use cases that
you wish you were a better fit for but
it's not
um you know talk to me about sort of the
the flip side for a second yeah
this is actually really interesting
really interesting conversation
about what i'm so you're saying
anti-patterns
what i'm hearing is how opinionated
should this library be
like people deploy it in all kinds of
different places um
it's a little bit like the classic
pattern of like what is a bug
in software right it's not doing what i
expect does that mean it's not doing
what it should
um so what i'll say is we're
we're actually doing a push internally
right now to think through
what are the core promises that great
expectations really needs to be able to
fulfill
and as we do that um i think we're going
to get a little bit more opinionated
about it uh and
it's too early to telegraph like exactly
where that goes but
in order to enable a really good
experience around
not just profiling one table but
profiling lots of tables
it turns out that like you need to think
about you know okay what's a table how
opinionated
are we about definitions of tables and
data assets and things like that
so it's not so much that i see people
doing like
you know bang your head on a wall dumb
things like that
not that it's more i think we're coming
out of
a phase where we've sort of deliberately
let a thousand flowers bloom
and from that we're seeing some patterns
that are clearly more productive
and what we want to do is help people
see the value in those specific patterns
and then figure out how you bridge from
whatever you were doing to that
and maybe that's an immediate quick
thing or maybe it's something that takes
more time
but so i think you know people should
expect to see
great expectations getting both sort of
better documented about
what are all the workflows that could be
supported but also opinionated about hey
if you're using this workflow
consider this alternative because if you
do the alternative we can also guarantee
x y and z for you
yep got it um i i guess maybe
slightly adjacent to that is this notion
of where you fit
in the overall data ecosystem because
that can help you
sort of determine on how opinionated you
want to be and of course
you and i have done some fun work
together on this recently
but what would you say that
uh what which tools does uh great
expectations quote play nicely with
yeah so just virtual high five that was
a fun blog post to write i'm looking
forward to seeing where the rest of them
go
um 25 hot data tools and what they don't
do
agreed um uh so i think
the strongest set of complements that we
see in this universe
are airflow and then all of the people
who are chasing airflow
uh so you know with
my impression i'm gonna go out on a limb
i i think of airflow as the jquery of
uh data orchestration and what i mean by
that
is it unlocked so many cool experiences
it it gave the people this notion of a
dag
um uh and like it worked really really
well for for a lot of things
however when you like start to build it
out and get to scale
it turns out that some of the
abstractions don't quite quite fit
and so like jquery's being superseded by
the the reacts of the world
i see the same kind of evolution
happening around dag orchestration
um and there are a bunch of players in
that space so
uh kedrow prefect uh mara if you want to
kind of go smaller uh dagster like
they're still
kind of sort of stealthy but they've
like taken a very very ambitious view on
where to go with that
um and several others uh
flight out of the lift team um so
it's clear that data orchestrators are
going to be a thing
and um yeah we see them as our natural
complements and in fact we're working
with several of those teams
to figure out how do we make integration
really seamless and
and beautiful between those tools um
it's a little bit messy because
all of the tools are still evolving and
growing uh and so figuring exactly how
to integrate is gonna take some time
but um yeah i think that's the natural
evolution
for this ecosystem got it
so you know sort of along those lines um
what excites you most about the biggest
vision
of what great expectations could become
like what is what does that look like to
you
both as a you know initial author of a
project
now a company founder which will
actually get some questions
on as well but what's your
like how how does this project change
the world
so i
love like i'm i'm not sure if i would
have
kind of strategically chosen to do open
source i i like to throw this out
i started off kind of skeptical about
open source business models
um and you know over the last year i
feel like i've gotten much more educated
i see how it works i see how it can fit
together um
i love that we're building great
expectations in this purely open
uh community driven way because i think
i think we create and it's like i'm not
dodging a question that this is a real
answer
um i i think we create the most value
and like
get to the biggest possible vision by by
being expansive and by bringing a lot of
people
in um the big change that
we feel over the last year as a kind of
the core team
is not thinking about it just as a data
testing tool
but making this bridge into other forms
of collaboration
so compile to docs and datadocs is part
of that
um profiling is also part of that it
turns out like when you start building
really good profiling workflows
often more than one person gets involved
and those people have different types of
technical skills
um and so
we we don't see it just as testing we
see testing as this like very clear
immediate entry point that engineers
recognize and see a
clear need for but once you've got that
established
as long as you also have the ability the
ability to be extensible
and to translate to human readable
things it opens up all of these really
interesting possibilities
for keeping different different people
on the same page about their data
so we see this natural evolution towards
something like a we think of it as a
data contract where
different stakeholders who all care
about data may have different needs
maybe maybe even have like
adversarial needs in some cases but you
know all come with a different
perspective
can all be confident that the data does
what they think it does
and they're confident that they know
that and everybody else knows that
um because the the technology is doing
the core validation
and then translation out to other layers
so
so is that is that looking is that like
an sla for data
um i mean is that sort of where you
think this this is heading
if you want to think about it that way
yeah yeah and
this actually goes to your earlier
question about like where do you deploy
it so
that's an sla that you could deploy at
etl to make sure the data coming in is
clean
it's an sla that you can deploy around a
data warehouse to make sure that the
business logic of
building out your analytics tables and
your reporting is clean it's a thing you
can deploy both up and down stream of
machine learning models to make sure
that the features come in as expected
and the models produce the things that
you know they produced last week and you
expect them to produce
you can deploy between teams you can
deploy it between companies so
we're seeing some interesting use cases
around data brokers uh sharing data
and people downstream either wanting to
guard themselves against unexpected
changes or
data providers wanting to be able to
give sort of self-enforcing data
dictionaries
along with their stuff so there are all
kinds of places where
this can be useful and
i i again going back this notion of open
source
um actually let me go personal for a
minute i
i have spent a lot of my time going back
and forth between
engineering and communication and i love
engineering a tool that helps with
communication that like helps people
stay on the same page
and so that that's the bigger vision
yeah that's significant um getting
buy-in from stakeholders you know
agreeing on common terminology these are
sort of the
soft skills of engineering that many of
us engineers
learn later in our careers because god
it's not the first thing we want to
learn
um but uh but they're super useful in
working in teams and so i appreciate
them to have that collaboration
communication mentality and value that
is obviously apparent
in the project um how does this relate
to the extensibility
of your plug-in architecture like let's
talk about that as sort of the bridge
to having the community conversation
which i want to get into as well
so there are several parts of so we
that this is an analogy that i've heard
several other open source projects that
i admire very much use
um i'm thinking of teams like gatsby or
hashicorp
um they talk about trunk and branch or
like
core and periphery i like trunk and
branch better because
i don't know periphery sounds like
you're not important and that's not
the case um there there are several
places
where the patterns for how to extend
great expectations are starting to be
pretty clear um so one is connecting to
more types of databases
another one is building out the logic of
additional expectations
another one that we've done less work on
but i think will be
big in the future is uh kind of post
post execution hooks to kick off other
jobs and workflows
uh integrate with other systems all of
those are places where
you can imagine you know dozens if not
more of
really good integrations and we're
starting to get to a place
where those are streamlined now i say
starting this is very much the same
place that we were with onboarding
back in november at data council where
onboarding was starting to get smooth
i i'd say contributing to the project it
entered like a
big like here's a discrete integration
and that can
that can be shepherded through very
quickly as a pr that workflow
is still not super easy but we're
working on it and uh that
you know as as more people show up in
slack saying hey i want to kept to maria
db
or i want to build a connection
downstream to matter most
or i want to extend the data docs to be
able to visualize this way
um we're steadily getting better and
streamlining the process of helping
funnel all that creativity
into one big shared open product
and is there a specific area that you
want to put the request out to the
community here
for support in most is it this data
sources
sort of option or connectivity are there
others
honestly i would say today if you're
interested
reach out there's a contributors
contributing channel in slack
just show up there and raise your hand
that i'd say the immediate need like
this week
is actually in our documentation we've
just gone through a
fairly large refactor documentation part
of what we're doing is breaking out
these how-to guides
that take one bite-sized piece of doing
something in great expectations
usually something you can do in less
than 10 minutes often less than two
minutes
and we're trying to make those really
discreet atomic lego blocks that people
can build their systems out of
um but there are a lot of them there are
almost 80 docks there that need to be
filled out
and it's it's swamping the core team to
develop those
so if they're people who are you know
good technical writers and don't you
know would like to get involved that
would be an awesome way to
put your stamp on things right away i i
know asking for help for docs
is a little bit different than what some
engineers are inclined to jump in on
first
that's what we need right today it'd be
awesome to get help uh in the future
things like data sources and
and more expectations those are coming
pretty soon too
got it um and how can folks um connect
with you there's twitter the best way um
on twitter or other ways as well
um so at apegong to get a hold of me uh
great expectations as a project
is expect great data at twitter
um and if let's see if you've got a
question that you think other
people might have you can also go to
discuss.greatexpectations.io
which is our community discussion forum
it's relatively new
uh but we were active there and we're
actually starting to
try and encourage people to shift
questions out of slack
into those discussion forums because
then again
it becomes a useful long-term thing for
the rest of the community to consume
great so so on the community front um
i'm sure you've learned a lot in the
last um year or two about managing an
open source project
um are there any tips or hacks that you
would
sort of recommend to others in terms of
how to successfully marshal the
community
around a project i mean i can tell from
your values and from reading your
documentation
that communication again means a lot to
you and it really shows from the docs
that you produce
so i think to me that's um very
meaningful table stakes
for any significant open source project
but um
would you add to that are there other
other things or tricks that you've done
that you might share with the community
i don't think it's so much about tricks
as just investing
in people um one way to think about it
is i i've been told kind of rule of
thumb
when a new engineer joins a team it's
usually about a month before they stop
being a drain
on the team right like it takes some
time to ramp up and get productive
and just be able to really fit in um for
open source
if it's gonna be like very few people
are gonna have the patience to like wait
around for a month and figure things out
so you got to figure out how to
streamline things you've got to do the
work of really
really streamlining your onboarding um
to be totally candid i don't think we've
fully done that yet i think we've done a
lot
in the last few months that makes it
easier but um
one of the things to to look for from
the project is
we're working to a place where we're
building out specific kind of
step-by-step how-to guides for
if you want to connect to a new data
source here's what you do like all of
the things here's how you test it here's
how you document it here's
everything um and then within that also
breaking out from a process perspective
what should you as a contributor expect
the core team to do like what kind of
turnaround times are reasonable
um where you know where is it common to
get specific types of feedback
um what things will the core team just
kind of do for you and what should you
expect to have to do for yourself
and it i feel like we're talking about
sla's a lot it's this
kind of sla around hey as a contributor
what can i expect
and um our goal is to make that
really like fast and convenient and easy
but doing that in and of itself like
it's a it's a sort of product
all of its own and so it's you know it's
taking real real time
it's fun though like i've seen people
use it that it's one of the most
rewarding things that
that i get to see well
um at the risk of boring folks by
talking about sla is longer
and also in uh but actually an
acknowledgement of the fact that we've
been chatting for 45 minutes
already and i swear that i would never
allow any live
live event um approach an hour why don't
we
take some questions from folks because
they've been sounding off on youtube
and so we have a bunch of great
questions lined up that i'm anxious to
hear your thoughts on so
first of all rick is asking
are there lessons to be learned from
existing software testing frameworks
especially those that have gotten the
most adoption
i guess that's so who do you look to for
inspiration um sort of question
that's a really good question um i think
we do feel a bit of a departure from
soft it's not a departure it's just um
existing unit and integration tests are
not a perfect analogy
for uh data testing again because of
this notion that the data is the thing
that changes
so um monitoring also matters we we take
you know quite a few cues from the
observability side of the world although
that also is not a perfect analogy
um i i don't know them deeply
but i've been really fascinated by a lot
of the front-end testing frameworks that
allow you to connect user stories very
directly
to testing of specific components um
again going to the the data world is
moving to be more like react and less
like jquery
i think there's some kind of high-level
buzzword
kind of analogies there i think there
are also some deeper technical analogies
that you can draw on
so yeah it's this interesting place of
looking to other examples while also
knowing that none of them is a perfect
fit for the
the new world that we're developing here
so flavian has another question hey
flavian
how do you handle the trade-off of
column level expectations
which is most of what i've heard geb
being used for
versus table level explications um
example
tabe revolt table volume being greater
than x
that's a really good question um we've
spent most of our early development time
on column level expectations
as your understanding one of the things
that we're starting to do
is set up more infrastructure for cross
table expectations or whole table
expectations
multi-column expectations that that test
relationships between columns
there's some really interesting things
you can do with kind of inferring state
machines
and correlations and things like that
um we've held back from that in the open
source
uh for two reasons one
you can build your own it it's not too
hard um and two
there's a pretty deep when you move into
that world
it's possible to express the same
assertions in many different ways
and um we want we want to be cautious
we want to feel our way forward to make
sure that there isn't like tons of
redundancy or wasted compute
or just confusion in the way that things
are documented here so it's actually a
fairly deep
um i call it a semantic problem there
like a fairly deep problem
saying like what is the best way to
express an idea or an assertion that
could be expressed in multiple different
ways
got it uh so listener from kabula
another data tool in the ecoboost system
is asking what's the best place for ge
in the typical ecl scenario does it
belong as
throughput testing or into a separate
pipeline
would processing data one more time be a
negative
i see i well i think i see um
it depends right so if you're if you're
working with really big data you don't
want to touch it more than once
um however if you're working with
relatives like
let me frame it this way when deploying
a tool like great expectations
you've got two options one is you can
sort of retrofit an existing system
and plug great expectations in on top of
it if you do that you'll probably have
some duplicate compute
but it's usually faster to deploy and
set up
so what we see is for teams that have
small to medium-sized data where it's
mostly variety not volume that's a
problem
that's usually the better fit if you're
in a system where you have
really large data being processed
through or if you want to have really
tight control
over how data gets processed so you
don't want to just proc uh
validate post talk but you want to
control the flow of your etl or control
the flow of your
actual code in that case you've got a
tighter integration to do
where you're actually deploying great
expectations checkpoints
within your code within other places um
so i mean i think that's the trade-off
one
one deploys faster and uh gives you
somewhat less control
and some perhaps less performance the
other one gives you
more control more performance but at the
cost of higher upfront engineering cost
got it so jennifer
is asking what's the ideal method in
this framework for creating new customer
expectations also how would this
framework allow for an expectation to be
embedded
in one or many pipelines
so this is one of those how-to guides
that i've
tried to get written this week if you go
there right now it's going to say it's a
stub
so if but the old docs do still exist
and if somebody wants to dive in help
write that
i'll get to it before too long but um
the short answer
is uh if you deploy great expectations
with what we call a data context as if
you run great expectations init and
set up all the moving parts one of the
things that you'll get is a built-in
plugins directory and
within that plugins directory you can
write
custom modules for your own expectations
when you do that
any data sources that import that that
use those
modules when they import which you can
configure to do by default
uh will have access to all of the
expectations that you've built and so if
you have
i don't know what expectation you're
imagining but
um expect column value to be prime
number
and you want that to show up everywhere
but building into a plug-in like that
makes it available anywhere that you're
validating your data so
it's almost as if it's just a member of
the core library
and again this this is part of what we
see as the long-term value plot for
great expectations
you define these semantically meaningful
concepts once and then they can get used
all over the place
so another question from paul and deep
he's asking um does ge play with other
data tools such as dbt
which is a favorite of ours which also
supports data tests
and are already being used in some
organizations so
that's sort of how do you play nicely
with dvt
question and when we were talking about
data orchestrators i knew i was
forgetting what dbt is it dbt is the one
i was thinking
of i'm sorry yeah
you're interested i'm sorry it was not a
purpose we'll apologize to fishtown
later
yeah yeah um so uh
we see a lot of teams that are deploying
great expectations alongside
um dbt i think um dbt
provides tests and and they do it well i
think the place where we see the most
value add for great expectations
is let me break it out this way
um some dbt teams are purely within the
data warehouse they live
in an almost entirely sql world and
within that world
dbt is like full stack covers everything
they need
um that actually well
i won't get into details but that's one
use case the other use case that we see
is
dbt is one component in a larger data
infrastructure system the the data
warehouse
exists and dbts does a wonderful job of
orchestrating it
and then there are all of these other
adjacent components that also need to
work a data lake machine learning other
things along of that nature
and in that case if you want uh
consistent testing that flows across all
of them and it gives you the
semantically meaningful
bindings we can be really helpful great
expectations can be really helpful level
up
from from the core test that dbt
provides um there are also some things
if you uh really invest in profiling
or kind of some of the more advanced
features around data docs um
there's a place where the kind of
declarative testing around great
expectations can also help
even just within a data warehouse but
i'm almost reluctant to say that because
dbt does such a good job
working in the data warehouse that like
you know we
we believe we can add value there but i
don't want to over promise um
especially when some of those features
are still early
well um abe i have to give you a lot of
credit because um
you know i was looking through your docs
in preparation for the show and
i realized that um not only was the blog
posts that we co-wrote together
but you mentioned your idea
but the whole notion of this concept of
what is your tool not do was your idea
and it's embedded in the great
expectation docs
and so um i just wanted to salute you
for
um you know acknowledging that with this
community and
really taking a lead in
being one of the first ones to sort of
come clean and
try to avoid the hype cycle and really
accurately
depict other engineers what they should
expect
from your tool and what they shouldn't
and you know i see that clarity
in the way that you communicate about
the project and in the way that you
think about the data ecosystem so
i'm really grateful to you for that and
i think it's a great
model for other tools and other
community leaders
um to show that same kind of
transparency and not pretend that
they do everything well because that's
just not the way um
you know optimizations work teams have
to optimize and tools have to optimize
for
values and for use cases and for
pleasing some people and not others so
i just wanted to thank you for the
clarity that you've brought to the
ecosystem
surrounding that concept and i just
wanted to put a plug for
other tool developers writing
documentation um to start to adopt a
similar notion of
being explicit and clear about what
their tool doesn't do
thank you i guess like yes thank you
i don't i mean i i think everybody's
better
when we recognize that there are lots of
like
technically deep interesting problems in
the data world it's not
one problem it's not one workflow there
are a lot of moving parts there's real
complexity
and um i i definitely am a person who
avoids hype
i one things i love about open source is
it keeps us very honest
right like there's there's no potential
for us to promise things that
it doesn't actually do um and
yeah i just i think that's the healthy
way for technology to evolve
yeah agreed well um it's almost an hour
so i think it's time for us to wrap up
um
i just wanted to mention to folks
listening
that we have another great episode lined
up
in two weeks we'll be featuring mark
grover who's a product manager at lyft
he's also the co-creator of amundsen one
of the data catalogs that we
mentioned briefly in our chat today um
so
you can find a register link in the
youtube description
now if you'd like to get eventbrite
reminders
about the event you can sign up there
it's mark grover
in two weeks from today same time same
place
um and abe will list other show notes
and links to great expectation related
stuff
in the youtube description as well so
that folks can have access to that
also there's a feedback form if folks in
the community are kind enough to
give us some feedback constructive
feedback on positive negative
we'd really appreciate that because it
would help us make pc thursdays
even better as we go forward but a big
thanks to you for
being the first guest i really
appreciate your um johnny on the spot
like agreeing to do it
um and uh and all your thoughts and and
the value that you add to the
community so thanks i hope it's been fun
for you it's been great
i just put in a plug mark's awesome you
should come back in two weeks and
talk not not you beat everybody's
listening mark's great oh i will
instantly i will be here
directions i know you'll be great well
thanks
well thanks abe um and thanks to the
community for tuning in we'll see you
next time